so take my hand now and follow me down
this rabbit hole it's going to take us
to some dark and horrifying places but
there are lessons to be learned along
the way
and we begin in the present day with a
journalist who now goes by the name
gabrielle mack
and identifies as a man though she is a
biological female gabrielle is featured
on the cover of the latest issue of new
york magazine in a story which she
penned herself titled my penis myself
i didn't need a penis to be a man we're
told on the cover but i needed one to be
myself
now the article goes into graphic gory
detail about gabriel gabrielle's quest
to surgically masculinize herself in
order to vaguely approximate the
appearance of a biological male i'll
i'll read only as much of the piece as
is needed to get the point across
i will tell you that the first line is
this
on the day that i heard my penis would
be huge i sobbed
that's the first line yes i mean what
man cannot relate to that experience
you know you're actually a man if you
select your penis out of a catalog
rather than simply you know being born
with one the article goes from there and
it gets more bizarre and certainly a lot
more nauseating here's a few morsels and
i'm kind of choosing bits somewhat at
random but um but here they are at one
point she says
i could not have gotten my boobs cut off
fast enough and i spent weeks before my
2019 hysterectomy up late in bed hot and
sleepless fantasizing about the moment
the medical waste disposal team at uc
san francisco would batch incinerate my
uterus which swirled with dysphoria like
nausea from the depths of my soul but
just as you might feel an automatic no
if a doctor offered to cut one of your
healthy arms off for you when i thought
about cauterizing excising and sewing
closed my vagina my whole body cringed
wrong
well yeah that is certainly wrong at
another point we're told
the whole process is constant body
horror barian a nurse said at one point
after he told me that the penis tip
discoloration i was worried about might
just be tissue that's dying off which is
also fine and this was a recovery with
no complications that required surgery
the overall proportion of
phallophalloplasties that's uh what they
call the surgery where they make a fake
penis that needs surgical revision while
lower for some surgeons including mine
is about one in two
the highest number of corrective
follow-up surgeries surgeries needed by
anyone i know personally is 12.
so did you get that one in two of these
surgeries has to be corrected
and there are people who have 12
corrective surgeries well that's totally
normal right 12 corrective surgeries
she also talks about the controversy
over this procedure even within the
trans community
she says phalloplasty in general it was
clear it was hard for people to accept
well i will love you no matter what
sweetie a cis female best friend of mine
said when i told her i was transitioning
years before
quote as long as you don't get it
one flatly demanded don't get it
it was another trans-masculine person i
used to know said disgusting insane to
want and to have a surgeon make a a
sensate phallus out of your arm or leg
or somewhere and frankenstitch it to
your body to go so far out of your way
to opt into a tool perhaps the tool of
so much suffering
is wrong she said most trans masculine
people didn't get one
the seminole print trans mask magazine
was named after not getting one it's
called original plumbing i saw trans
masculine support groups shut down and
go silent more than once when someone
brought up the procedure and later when
i was that someone i was twice invited
to leave with other people who might
want to talk about that
now so she doesn't hide from the fact
that this procedure
is dangerous
where they make a fake penis and they
stitch it to your body in fact the
procedure kills people
but that also seems to be a potential
perk from her perspective
she says it has happened at least once
that someone did die from the procedure
i was fully ready to by which i mean i
just spent nearly the last of my savings
which i'd burn navigating the uh social
medical legal extreme mind
f
show of transitioning on a burial plot
just in case
so she bought herself a burial plot
before the procedure again
totally normal
one of the nodding heads in the group
belonged to a non-binary white person
who was still horizontal in recovery
from having had a week prior the worst
happened which was that after their
procedure in which all the fat and skin
had been stripped from their left
forearm from wrist to nearly elbow along
with major nerves and artery and veins
and then shaped into a tube and
connected in careful layers to skin and
blood vessels and nerves in their pelvis
their new penis had failed
it died on them but here they were
already getting ready for their surgeons
to harvest a whole other part of their
body within a month with zero hesitation
because those three those three days
they'd had their penis they said before
being rushed into an eight-hour surgery
that couldn't save it the feeling of it
even just for one moment
even still bloody and painful and packed
with stitches
made it all worth it
now if this all sounds totally insane um
then get a load of this line
she says but when penis is self as penis
is a gift to self it's a gift too to
others
my penis is a gift to others she says
there's a an interesting pick up line i
guess you could try
and yet penis itself is the more
revealing phrase here because she sees
the self as being contained within a sex
organ penis is self
that might be if i had to pick any
three words to sum up
the leftist ideology it might be
that yourself is contained by your sex
organs or in this case an artificial sex
organ
a sex organ constructed from flesh
hacked off of your own body
now this is probably a good time to show
you the picture if you haven't seen this
if there could possibly be a good time
for that here's the cover of the
magazine
um with a gabrielle mac and you see
her in her underwear
with a huge hole dug out of her thigh
there you can see that in the thigh
but you also notice something else the
sad thing here if we can select just one
sad thing from this tragic
grotesque spectacle
and and that is that she still doesn't
look at all like a man
right she has wide hips kind of an
hourglass figure
she's very small and petite
now she doesn't look like a woman
certainly but neither does she look like
a man
she's in sort of a gender purgatory
what we find is is that we can reject
the gift of our own physical selves by
mutilating our bodies
but what we cannot do is create a new
self
you know when it comes to ourselves
we have only the power to maintain or
destroy not to create
if you if you choose to destroy yourself
you'll be left with this
which is what all trans people who get
surgeries are left with
you're left living in a prison of your
own making
stuck like that forever
but i told you this story gets darker um
and it does
gabrielle mack has extensive experience
doing violence to herself in fact back
in 2011 when she was still a journalist
named mac mcclelland and still
identified as a woman
she wrote an article for good magazine
where she describes staging her own
violent rape
now mcclellan wrote at the time that she
met a woman in haiti when she was in
haiti uh you know uh
i think she was working for mother jones
and she was as a journalist in haiti
station there
and um a year prior to this so 2010 she
was in haiti and she met a woman who had
been gang-raped by a group of men
now this experience meeting this woman
supposedly caused trauma for her for
mcclelland
she was the one who had the trauma and
after talking over with her therapist as
she explains in this article she wrote
the two decided that the best way to
overcome this trauma would be to stage
her own rape
and so she enlisted a helpful friend to
have violent sex with her while
suffocating and beating her
and and she went through it then she
says the experience was cathartic and
healing
now
what this tells us first and foremost is
that mcclellan is a deeply disturbed
mentally ill person
and we would have known that even
without her background of
therapeutically raping herself but that
detail drives the point home i think
but then again i think i think mentally
ill is kind of too broad a category to
be useful here
more specifically we should say that
that mcclellan suffers from a very
potent and very toxic mix of psychotic
narcissism and self-loathing
and those two things not only can go
hand in hand but almost always do
she's a narcissist because she's totally
obsessed with
herself she can't think about anything
but herself
that's all she thinks about all she
writes about
a woman in haiti was gang-raped
and somehow that became a story about
her
and her own trauma
she fetishized someone else's rape and
then wrote about it proudly in a
magazine
this is such a perfectly narcissistic
move that it ought to be included as an
example of the word in the dictionary
but she also hates herself that's why
she wanted to be beaten and brutalized
she's turned on by the idea of someone
abusing her because she despises her
herself
she says that the fake rape was a
successful form of therapy and and she
was healed from the experience not
surprisingly that turns out to be untrue
because she spiraled from there spinning
around in circles of self-loathing and
narcissism until she committed the
ultimate act of self-hating narcissism
by mutilating her body and attempting to
construct a brand new self
out of the pieces
you know constructing a self out of the
pieces of the old self like her body was
nothing but a box of legos or a potato
head doll she sees the self not as a
complete and coherent thing but as
fragmentary
a collection of arbitrary parts each
meaningless in its own right adding up
to a whole which is also meaningless
of course there's a very serious logical
problem with all of this i mean many
logical problems but here's one
we're told that gender is meaningless
anyway
we're told that penises have nothing at
all to do with manhood
we're told that a penis is only
arbitrarily associated with being a man
it has no actual bearing on the matter
so
what's the point of the operation
isn't getting a penis in that case like
getting a beak or feathers or having a
three additional fingers attached to
your left hand
it's a totally random and unnecessary
bodily addition which has no inherent
meaning whatsoever
that's what gender theory tells us
and yet gender theory also propels women
to chop off their breasts and have fake
penises attached to their crotches in an
effort to be men it's totally confused
and that's by design
can any thinking human look at this
disturbed person
and listen to her story
and conclude that sex change surgery is
what she needed
should it not be clear that her sickness
is in the mind not the body
isn't that obvious for everyone who
seeks out these kinds of procedures
it is of course but the argument starts
to feel futile when you realize
that the people pushing this kind of
frankenstein butchery
aren't making any sincere attempt to
help the mentally afflicted people who
seek it out
they aren't worried about the logical
problems much less the moral problems
it is in the end all about destruction
so when i sit here and say this is
destruction what they say is well yeah
thanks for noticing
destruction of the so-called gender
binary
destruction of truth
of science
destruction of beauty
destruction of society of civilization
and it all begins
at the most fundamental level
with the destruction of the self
which is what we have here well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content